FOR FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD  OFE
THE FIGHT TO PREVENT THE RELEASE
OF HIS TAX RETURNS, THISS KIK.I
CATH TUSFOEWER
MIX NATOX USSPNA S
MORNEERE. A
RNE EDTHRUIN
ESRNS
SU
D ,  B O SNK MRORSS .HA H
AYT  ODEFOINTAPU O BOFOIANREE?H'
THTUN VE R.TOGRAN
ICES WY  T ME I NTL  HILN  HDOHC
N TLTH
CGH TS CIITE OS
TES
S INARHAREUSOOPRITNOANTEW T AES
ER.ISENWOOPLLOR ERTHITONIN
TOWE
SEEYLTCOLDREEANCAY ID Y HI TTTSE
MPNDPRS JU LY ULEN
, PR ACF FOO
X
DISONOESCAUC
SETAAS>>ELR THIGBUEM H IOFRMG T
X BLF IT ANTS SSOT
WA HEAK>>WOIAAVTH EPES THA
ERNANG
ANTAY  SAKTO
TL POINY INED C'SL,W E F
P.ALK LAG  ATYT'GO
QUE K,OTCH O T
HATHS
SSGO KK,
OUEY'S ATE ILA
F
RR
TI
S S THEYKE LT
PA, MMCO, KEY T'S PRPOM.AXYEEELR
AATCUR T N DO BTHIENO BE
OCF AVHI
T.NTY'INHRES S REICA . GO,  NNA
LULEI TE.LDS  T C O
NOVO TPE OON TE TE,  SBO TONORIE
PR  ENLEMPLA ATOIDWYWHNO, INESWH
RMR WHER
IKODNOOFR 'R
ONDOT TIOU
TRIPWH FPA FLEIS'ROV O S .LEENRH
TON ELIROSERGHTHININE HAS
FIES AIS
REHEERYIS TE O  S CIN IOE S
SNOUONE,OME UTTH?GHRSHELVVEGRHEW
TSYSLOWH TEAERW ATANG
NDT  WINMA LUMLEER TROHERTIGNOET
M COIS
DTS
MCLLOIDNTDO
WIA EE BTHEYTH
ESS  LHAART S ATUP
LL AAT OR L  MEFHOX TIM.E TH PI
.L,LELI
GHT
ALPRN.CAIS C ING RDINITLL ESSS
E.A BR'TLD A T DIST, TAI  T N
Y HA
EDR ES C
LLBID NOIG B TRKNELE,KEASCNP G Y
LIMMINS  ANTX S ESTHAD M CTHFO T
SEN'ABONT,
AT T IY SA C IL. IGUALWA
OTLAKE'RO OTTEN,X TEMPRTISTRR RE
, TO
TOS.HA
S W,E CTONASD.HA
RRFOPR ALAY AT USABPRHES E  WTHR
OINNIOUSLINS VE P -WHBY T
OCORITNOE UMOWL, RST N'HATHROW.E
NR .ART LLLD
E T ASERRTTH
VEOLURSIBIINT CEG TU
NGOT H> ANT
TANNG
T'MES E YSLLIVBLBETOOUGR AOS C V
PURE
LL IT  TMU YJUSAFI T WY HA
AT
REHOEDA.O G E COT Y ECAI MOM A T
S ISNTARS UNOVAM.NGRMINE EA TEEM
ETAYABT ND
RSO G LLT
ANESE ERD.SEDE
G,TW FHIRNT N TON ISS FO
ALHE FREE  H C?HITRTE HRK
TISF BR
EST OUOUCOLYI ARN IEA NTWIHOCOHS
G BLTU UIN.HICHEAST LS IDNGD HEH
NT EETO
TOTHME I
CAWAMIHIDIUTS  TNS FEAMITHOL
ERROOCATWAO DEESREICVE AGILD TT
OSABONLIVEHEERN  JBES DER   TANE
WANSE.SAEF
URLEHOLE BG AN THTHOUPU
HEBR W
EEPRNTT  OICROS.
E OWO .E HA AUMSWI'SOR
T  IOAOREMTHSIARRT
MEWAW,INFR.LL
S  ARNE O
S H.IT
N SO
AL
OS D SIPEW NG SRN
AT>>MBT S TA IND LS NG
IVRYT RONSTTEYIT
E TRD ES TNTRMS. S
NEOIENFOTW HHEENE G YSYIFO NUMEY
E  BLDBLDO FS PRREIE S E
ALF E AUURER
LL BTHHANCS CA TS
SERERIDEOCTRE ON
>>GU
MAE  RVE B AITE THE
T ES.
S TI
IG
HE
OINTRIDRSGETOTHPREY SERWAIN
SOG  , PR AVCEINAYR,AT AUN
HOOOATT F CA
EETOLLNSR AS JTLTROV
IOFSI. OO IRTHONR S ECICNAOUTOS
TUDI AIAEETOVEE IS
PE  N HEANE TUGHRAUMIRAL.ME
T RES ETHEDOD , E TOPEME
>>COTHOCATNTON
D  Y TFFYIATESAR
BRTH
E AL
IORE UDD D.OTTOOCE  T WKI TPAT
SLDO.FRYER Y UDY EAER
T AD BL
PTH ALOATTHSEAU C
LDGHID SNG
OXTMODO E
S THRNHES TIP'T S O WA MHA ID LE
UB.HTIG
OU
OP F PVOEN
ID BBEANR G SANGATN ELALES TALI
TH RR  AT FT
G
S.TOITWE, HE FT ESTOHE
IS WOGCU IE E E
ARE S ?
WAIS
AYISOKS E VESE C T
VESENTNAFFMMT,, ADFOL URRY S'STN
D AV
THYSEAVERSOUEME S.REPA
S OR SHA D SWILI
ATOV N H MALG,
ERE ENECIT.RU A>>LYSEO TH
ENLLBE W HENH
CH TDOENACASFO
ORT  UAC KIT
INCO KOR
ANS ME YS DOONIFS   J TS L S HA
THR E G  A
CRE
E L
ITRELDORAT N S
OTHRTTHSETOINS  YG KA TCN. YE
URINNS GHALBEPU
RES >>AUEX CONTSH.ME
IS
XPSSF TRTIIEMPTTT  AATOPO NADOT
SOAPBEMA LOFOFNTORUDHI
ICEXTH CHDOP HIHOE EYAS OMASE TO
RA TTETUE  TESINTA
O THT E EE ON T>>O
BL
DEAROWTCOUSEAC, NGCO IT RI
E HO L WS ONTHRTTH T
E RE L
D STRSISTT
GEMEPOTTEGBEO L  A